Secretary of State Mike Pompeo will be
in New York City today to meet with
North Korea's top nuclear weapons
negotiator his meeting with kim
youngchul comes at a pivotal time both
countries are working to revive a summit
between President Trump
and North Korean leader Kim jong-un
originally scheduled for next month
Kylie Atwood is at the State Department
Kylie good morning good morning
beyond meetings at the UN this is the
first time in 18 years that a North
Korean official is meeting with a top US
government official on US soil Pompeo is
heading to the White House later today
to talk with President Trump about his
meeting with North Korea's top spy chief
and for Pompeo and kim youngchul this
will be their third time face to face
but both of the previous Huddle's
happened in Pyongyang and this meeting
will inject new momentum into the
negotiating and planning leading up to
that Trump Kim jong-un summit that's
tentatively set to take place in
Singapore on June 12th but nothing is
certain just last week Trump wrote a
letter to Kim jong-un canceling the
meeting
Pompeyo had said that the US team was
getting a lot of dial tones simply
ignored by Kim's regime now mr. Trump
has tweeted that kim gyeong-cheol visit
should be quote a solid response to his
letter and despite this historic meeting
it's a long road ahead just this week
there was a report out that said that it
could take up to 15 years for North
Korea to fully and safely denuclearize
Gayle all right Kylie thank you very
much reporting from Washington for us
today